[Music]
our 26 year old son told us last summer
that he's been taking female hormones
for two years
he said that he wants us to call him
rachel how do we open the line of
communication with him and build our
relationship so one thank you for your
trust this one's this one's hard
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john dalone's show
hope you're doing well hope your
family's well hope life's treating you
okay
man you can hear my voice about four
octaves deeper
could be puberty or could be the spring
allergy season in nashville it's a
toss-up um hope you are doing super well
though and uh we got a
a long show ahead of us today so let's
get right to it let's go to leslie in
richmond virginia what's up leslie
thank you so much john i understand
there's allergies we've got those here
too everybody's got it i'm i'm hoping
that's what it is yeah so i i i
it makes me sound i don't know like
cooler more wise like i'm tough i don't
know i i imagine listen to you
absolutely thank you for giving me that
listen
hey so what's up how can i
well first of all thank you so much for
your program i started listening several
months ago and i started from the first
episode i've made it to january 2021 so
i have learned so much and thank you so
much
hey so i haven't done that in fact i've
listened to a grand total of none of
these shows is it getting better that
might be for the best is it getting
better it is oh and remarkably
remarkably i have noticed so much i mean
it started out great and it has just
done nothing but improved it was pretty
wobbly it was not great i mean i used to
watch james went home he was on a lot he
was just taking tums by the i mean it
was tough and
kelly was drinking i mean not drink a
lot she wasn't drinking a lot i'm just
she wasn't she wasn't i told her i
wouldn't make that joke anymore a lot of
coffee a lot a lot of coffee
and um
and creatine and other positive
supplements protein shakes things like
that but anyway thank you so much i
appreciate that all right so how can i
help you i've got a lot going on
in my life right now i'm in my mid 50s
and
had some issues with my both of my grown
sons but the thing that i'm calling
about today is our 26 year old son told
us last summer that he's been taking
female hormones for two years
he said that he wants us to call him
rachel okay and then about a month later
he moved to houston to live with his
partner who is also a trans woman okay
about once a week i text him just to
make sure he's okay and he texts back
but other than i'll call it christmas we
haven't spoken
my husband and i have made plans
to visit him in late june we told him
that we have no agenda but that we love
him and we miss him okay
my question is
how do we deal excuse me now take your
time take your time
yeah how do we deal with the
name pronoun issue
if calling him rachel and using feminine
pronouns
compromises our values
then how do we open the line of
communication with him and build our
relationship
uh this is yeah so one thank you for
your trust this one's this one's hard um
it is uh
so
let me back out a little bit um
tell me why over the last year or so or
let me ask you before that was this is
total shock to you a surprise to you he
how would you say he was
26 26 okay okay so he had he had um
moved out to go to college and that
didn't go well but he was living with
the um roommate what does not what does
not go well what does not go well mean
he didn't do well in college he's um
i'm academically socially intelligent
but academically academically mainly
okay um but it's because
i'm i'm not really sure the issue what
the issue is there because he's super
smart he um he could tell you just about
any line in the narnia series i mean
he's just super super smart
but um
so let me see well i'm sure so that tell
so having worked with college students
for the major vast majority of my career
i ran into that a lot and that suggests
there were other things going on in his
life
or in her life definitely i'm i'm i'm i
don't doubt that at all okay um
so as far as going back to whether it
was a shock to us being a trans woman
was a shock to us we suspected there
were things going on and i suspected
even though he'd had a girlfriend for
six years
when he broke up with her
um i really strongly started suspecting
that he was having
um
you know
i don't know just you know i just
figured there was something going on but
i didn't know that it was the trans
woman i had no clue so that hit us out
of the blue so i i don't know gloss over
did you think i i've got inklings that
my son's gay
right yeah okay all right his roommate
his roommate seemed gay but um i they
didn't seem to be in a relationship i
mean he called me from two hours away to
come get him when he had kidney stones
instead of asking his roommate to take
him to the hospital
so i didn't really see them in a
relationship but i could tell that he
was very feminine yeah well well i
um
so i've got a number of gay friends that
i'm not in a relationship with so just
just just being in proximity doesn't
doesn't mean anything
um all right and that's how i saw it at
the time yeah i
um
here's what i'm asking i i've had this
conversation i can't count the number of
parents i've sat down i had this
conversation with and it's not it's not
rare it's rather common not always but
rather common what you just said i
felt that my son was or or daughter was
struggling
was having some identity like
questioning who they were and what they
were um and we're all
so there's there's a lot of layers to
this and so i'm going to walk through it
backwards forwards okay and we'll get
i'll get to your to your your final
question here but i want to address you
and your husband along the way here
right thank you the guilt
and the
regardless of what the outcome is
whether it's an uh
an outcome that you have a agreement
with alignment with value with whatever
there's i've never yet that's not true
i've met a couple and they're jerks i've
never met parents
or rarely met parents
who don't feel guilt along the way that
i can't believe my kid was wrestling
with something so heavy and i i wasn't
there to walk alongside him right
and it's it's that it's a parents bang
their head against the wall and they
feel deep shame and often the result
the actions that come next come out of
that shame and i should have been there
and i can't believe my kid was hurting
like that all alone and fill in the
blank
and whether you agree with the pronouns
or the anything you agree with that or
not
everybody can agree that kids that are
are wrestling with gender identity am i
a man am i a woman who am i going to be
who am i going to love
that they are really going through a
hard hard time like there's elevated
suicide arrests elevated mental health
challenges
devastating time
and so as a parent
gosh i wish i'd been there right so it's
important for you to own that and it's
going to be real important when you
re-engage with your child okay
okay um
that you come to the table with
with
here's what i'm feeling and we should
have been there for you i'm sorry right
there there's that sense of whether you
like should or shouldn't have been he
also or she also had was an adult and
could have had to come back right he had
a responsibility to talk to you it is
what it is
i think it's important to be open with
how you feel so then um
they moved to houston
and they've got a relationship why have
you just texted what has waited what has
taken you so long
to engage
right well we text about once a week
because i just need to know that he's
okay but why haven't you gotten a plane
and come in and and
looked your child in the eye and said i
love you um
right um
well my my job makes it so it's easier
for me to go
once um when i have a break
so um it'll be easier for me to go now
but i don't know why i have no answer
for why i didn't go
earlier
um i've been wrestling with so many
things but um i don't think that we've
ever well i can honestly say we've never
had good communication in our home
with any of us we're not good at
communicating we're great communicators
but not together
and that's what i have seen when i've
evaluated the past
and that's what i'm trying to fix with
both of my children
so
i'm gonna be pretty direct with you is
that okay okay that's okay
i don't care about your job and i don't
care about how easy your job it was it's
easier on a break or whatever
right exactly
your child came to you and said
mom i'm hurting
and you've spent the last six months
texting
and so
that's one of those moments
it's not to change the outcome not to
what there's not an roi on this
right there is a you're my baby
right and i know you're hurting
and i know you've been sitting here
right after we found out he came and
spent a week with us okay before he
moved to texas and how did that week go
it went it was like normal we didn't he
didn't seem feminine and it was so
normal and we had kind of normal
interactions we fell into our same
routine
i had one talk with him that was
um that
that was very a very good talk with him
that was positive mostly positive 90
positive okay with him during that week
but because we just don't have good
communication
hey listen listen
you are the parent
right good communication starts with you
right and so it's not this amorphous
thing that we just don't have like money
like we just don't have money okay yeah
good communication is a choice
okay so i haven't learned how to have a
good conversation with my children okay
here's where that starts and ends with i
love you
and i'm so glad you're my child
full stop period at the end of that
sentence and then we're just gonna hug
for a while
that's where it starts
there's not a sophisticated entry
there's not a
there's not a it doesn't need to have
like a
like a
bunch of check boxes it starts with i
love you and you're my kid
i can do that
and there will come seasons when they'll
look at you and say why now
what happened at 14 and what happened at
18 and there's going to be some guilt
there and there's going to be some shame
there's going to be some frustration
there
and what you'll have to do is own what
happened
it is and you'll have to look at your
kids and say i was the adult
and i didn't have good communication and
i'm sorry
and what i can only think i can do now
is get better moving forward
that's i mean that's your choice or the
other choice is just to continue to walk
around we just don't have good
communication in our house
we just don't have it yeah yeah
no i don't i don't i don't want to do
that
so
jump in with both feet
okay okay
and
don't let me say it this way don't over
complicate it
okay don't over complicate it
um that's good for me to hear because i
do that yeah don't
and
let you here's where you are now now
you're at a place where you need to be
super super super honest
i put my job before this relationship or
i waited for things to get convenient
and quite honestly i was scared because
i didn't know how to do it and i'm sorry
yeah that's it that nailed it and so
listen they have felt that for 26 years
your kids right right they felt the gap
they felt that's more important or this
is more important or
the not feeling uncomfortable having a
conversation with us was more important
than having a conversation with us
they felt that gap and they've spent
their entire life trying to bridge that
gap or figure it out or just completely
disconnect from it
and so
most
it took a close friend of mine sitting
down with me and this is probably 15 or
20 years ago
and walked me through
how heavy
a coming out narrative
is right the phone call
was probably weeks or months if not
years in the making
and it was
really hard to do
even if you get that right so so here
was like
the back end of that is i'm getting on a
plane
or i'm putting you on a plane
right and
early on he shared some reading material
with me and i read through everything he
sent me that's fine that's fine so okay
so let's get to the let's get to the
okay but see here's the thing you don't
need more data right now you need
relationships exactly you don't need
more info there's not a thing he's gonna
tell you and you're gonna go oh okay
right and vice versa
there's not an argument you're gonna
give him and he's gonna be like you know
what i've i didn't know that that's not
the way this is gonna play out right now
exactly okay
he needs his mom
right or she needs her mom like what
whatever pronoun y'all decide to use so
let's go there here here's the deal
your child has put a boundary down
and said
this is
me right now and this is me moving
forward
you have your values
and what you have to decide
is my relationship with my child
more or less important than a previously
established value
that's the conversation to have
what you can't do is say
um we won't have a relationship with you
on our terms
because
or she has told you what their terms are
and that's the hard part you find
yourself in
well part of the struggle has been this
whole feeling like i don't know this
person he wants to be called rachel i
don't know this person rachel
rachel
you know it feels like he killed like
rachel killed my son yeah
so and here's here's the other side of
this conversation that never gets
brought up
you're allowed to feel that way
right and you're allowed to feel sad and
you're allowed to have had plans and
pictures of grandkids in your head and
what thanksgivings are going to look
like in years and now that picture is
very very different you're allowed to
grieve that too
and that's left out of the conversation
um
you're allowed to do whatever you want
to do because you're an adult
right the fewer secrets the better
for everybody
right
and
um you're right
you don't know your child
you don't
and it's probably been that way for a
long long time you had a an image of
your child that you i thought i knew him
right and i would say even
if he wasn't uh or she wasn't choosing
to change their gender
um
you still wouldn't know your child
you would have a you know
you
your
rachel could still still be dan and have
a wife and five kids
and you would not know your child
and maybe that's the entry point i love
you
and i don't know you
and i want to get to know you because i
love you okay
and
you will have to decide
and every family's got to make these
choices and i'm not going to let i'm not
going to give you a pass and give do it
for you
you've got to choose
we can have relationship with our child
or not
right and if we are
then my child has established some
boundaries
and some expectations and we have to
decide whether we're going to meet those
or not
and here let's let's take let's take the
the transgender thing the the because
that's a third real issue let's take
that move it away
this happened with
if you're going to come to my house you
have to wear a mask be on my kids
or
you can't wear a mask in my home i don't
want my kids seeing that kind of stuff
or you have to be vaccinated or you
can't drink or
you can't come the day before christmas
because we're going somewhere
children put down boundaries and then
parents have to say these are our values
are we going to
expand shift change modulate out of
or double down on
our previous values
or are we going to double down our
relationship
i hear you that makes sense
yeah it makes sense it makes a lot of
sense
how much of this
is about
your child
how much of this is about being caught
off guard
and how much of this is about
how am i going to tell my friends
and my faith community and my
whatever because a lot of times i hear
it's about embarrassment
right well initially there was some of
that but i have some experience in a
counseling field and so
um
i
i'm very open with people okay i am more
so than my husband is
um
i would go and i would you know i would
go and tell everybody just because this
might help you that's how i am i'll tell
you my experience because it might help
you okay and my husband is nobody needs
to know our business okay that's that's
fair my house is very similar to that
um yeah
so
to simplify everything
your child has said
this is where i'm at and do you love me
and you have an answer
you have a choice to make
right
and it may be that
um your answer is different than your
husband's answer
it may be that y'all's answer is
together it may be your answer is we are
going to
double down a relationship first and
engage in a series of conversations over
the next few years but the conversations
aren't debates or discussions or
whatever the debates are the the
conversations are just want to get to
know you
right and that's what i want yeah so
that's that's where i'd start that's a
humble
um
control alt delete place to start
right
and as far as something i've been
wondering as i've been listening through
your program and you talk about i don't
know if you're still talking about it
but in the part that i've listened
you've talked a lot about having like a
formal funeral or something like that so
i've wondered if i should
if if that would be helpful i thought
about it a little bit
if you're there
i mean if that if that's where this
ultimately ends up i think it's always
good
you know yeah i i wouldn't have a
funeral
of your child yeah because your child is
still fully alive um right but not i
mean about that dream that i had of the
person i thought he was gonna be it's
important to acknowledge i had this
picture of my head
not that he or she created but that you
created
and you put expectations into the world
that your child was going to fulfill
that they are under no obligation to
fulfill and every parent on planet earth
does this by the way you're not the only
one oh yeah you know what i mean oh yeah
and so
um something as little in my home is i
just always played baseball and my dad
always played baseball and my son was
awesome at baseball and then he came to
us over the holidays and said hey
um
would it be cool if i didn't play
baseball and instead i did theater
i did theater too i did in college i
loved it and
i just had a picture of my kid playing
baseball all the way through
and so i didn't have a big funeral i
didn't have a bit but i had to stop and
go yeah of course you can man and i was
really proud of him for having the
conversation with us and coming to us
with it and um
communication is a big deal in our house
and so i'm so proud of him for doing
that because i know it was hard for him
and
i had to go
i kind of had pictures i don't know
where they came from i just had pictures
of us going to high school baseball
games and we're not going to do that
and so yeah it's important to hold that
i wouldn't have a funeral for your child
um right i mean i guess i've thought of
that because it has felt so much just it
feels like a death right but i know it's
a death of a dream that i have it's
grief yes
and you're allowed to grieve and anybody
that tells you otherwise is is
not being honest with you you're allowed
to say i hoped or had pictures of this
and something else is happening you can
also grieve how much pain your kid's
been in for a long time
because whether you believe with the in
the outcome and that's a whole other
conversation if you believe and
transgender this and that's a whole
other conversation
everybody can agree your kid's been
hurting for a long time
sounds like both your sons have been
hurt for a long time and given your like
your honesty about how you struggle with
communication and how work comes first
and then when it's convenient well
it's time you start and say i'm sorry
and i'm ready to do this thing
from the floor up
and i'm going to grieve what we lost
together i'm going to agree that i
wasn't there for you when you were
hurting
and now i'm going to do the best i can
to walk alongside you whatever that
looks like or you can choose no
you can choose hey if this is what you
need and as the person you're choosing
to become
your dad and i are opting out
that's your choice
people ask me um my opinion on stuff and
i tell them what i would do
and i'll tell you i'm going to choose
relationship with my kids every time
we'll be right back
have you ever thought about how a lot of
us would drop anything to help somebody
else but we often don't give ourselves
the same level of care we spend time
energy money on everyone else but when
it comes to making time for vacation for
exercise for talking with a mentor for
sleep even going to therapy
we don't do it and we don't even realize
they wouldn't even think about it you
are worth it
this month betterhelp online therapy
wants to remind you that you are
important
that you are worth being well and
therapy is a super important way you can
show up for yourself
better help is online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist you don't
even have to see anyone on a camera if
you don't want to it's more affordable
than in-person therapy and you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours today dr john deloney show
listeners get 10 percent off their first
month so decide to invest in yourself
you are worth it and go to
betterhelp.com to get 10 off that's
betterhelp.com delony
all right we're back let's go to sarah
in indianapolis what's up sarah
hi dr john this is so wild to talk to
you it's more wild to talk to you i
promise how are you oh
i'm doing good doing good
yeah how about you
it's exact same doing pretty good
so what's up how can i help
well i feel like a silly goose after
that last caller that was heavy man
hey man there it yeah there is no
comparison i mean there's no like
comparing heaviness man it's everybody's
heavy is heavy to them so that's awesome
so what's up
i guarantee you what you're about to
drop is big so go go oh it's really
um okay
so
all right um
my husband has
friends from college that are having a
bachelor party at the end of this year
and there i'm a thousand percent sure
there's going to be um strippers
involved
uh
that's a that's a that's a a strong
degree of certainty there
i mean well yeah
that it's awesome that's the that's
their guy you know that's just like what
they're into uh
my husband has made it clear to me in
the past that's like not his jam but
like you know those friends and whatever
um and this the reason why it's like a
bigger deal this time is because like
right before we got married like he's
made our whole relationship he's like
yeah i went in college but you know like
if i don't like it like i just you know
i'd like to do with my buddies and stuff
um and then you know about a week before
we got married he had somebody else's
boobs in his face
and yeah so so he did this for his
bachelor party
well okay his buddies you know
took him but yeah
so
anyway
poor guy just got forced right into it
huh right oh it's so sad
i'm really sorry that
well
the thing is like i like to think of
myself as like a cool chick you know
like i like dirty naughty fun like i'm
all about it like a good time it was
just like a weird betrayal because like
he told me like he wasn't gonna was good
so hold on whatever it's not a weird
betrayal it's a
regular old spit in your face betrayal
that's what it felt like
that's what it was
it was
honestly
yeah
and if it hadn't been you know the week
before our wedding and everything's said
and so i probably wouldn't have married
him but i'm glad i did i love him we've
been good since then you know we sought
it out
we you know we have a son like
everything's good now
um but now it's like i'm like
oh god what do i do because that's not
good now
it's nothing i don't know
oh no don't tell me that well i mean
you're
nothing has changed
you have a you have a boundary
and you have said
this violates what my understanding of
covenant is
okay
and this is important to me
and he has said i don't know where i'm
at with it though is like the thing like
i don't because there i have like three
sides that i like ping pong around all
right let's play ping pong
it's like okay we're solid i'm cool like
this is fun like go out and have fun i
know it doesn't mean anything like if
she doesn't care that's her job like she
doesn't care about you and then i'm like
well
you know
screw him if he wants to do that then i
don't want to be with him anyway and
then i go
to the other side where it's just like
i don't know i don't know that's
cheating
even though you pay for it that's
cheating like some eyes like ping pong
between these three different
feelings
and it's like i just don't
i shared that if he goes i'm gonna
represent him and then i'm scared if he
doesn't go he's going to resent me
because i don't want to give him roles
ew like i'm not his mom you know what i
mean
oh
sweet sarah
oh man you're like the best in every
category you're just the best
okay wow
so
um
oh there's so much here geez louise
um
you do have thoughts and feelings on
this
and i don't wanna
i know you don't want them
and
here's what i think
i think the thought
of
some other woman shoving her breast in
your husband's face makes you sick
yeah cause it's our thing man i do that
okay there you go that's your job and it
makes you sick and then layered on top
of that is well i want to be cool
and i want him to keep loving me
and on top of that is
but it makes me sick and so on top of
that it's like well i mean it doesn't
mean anything whatever
so let's take
ch
this in my and this is totally me okay
this is less about
a strip club
this is more about i have values
and i have boundaries
and your values are important and your
boundaries matter
and
the first time your husband spit on him
and then just walked right through
and so he he banged up against your
boundaries and they didn't hold
and
you
not him you are the one who've had to
deal with picking those bricks back up
and putting the wall back up the
boundaries back up
and now it's coming again
and so this is less about is this
cheating or is this not am i the cool
wife whatever i've got friends whose
wives don't care
and i've got friends whose wives like
couldn't breathe when they caught their
husband with a bra ad out of a sunday
paper right so everybody's got different
values
yeah it is
asinine completely asinine
to say that going to a strip club is not
extramarital
sexual encounter full stop
now where like me and my wife disagree
on the conversation is i think cheating
is about secrets
and like i think you can cheat by going
to get coffee with somebody
like so i think cheating is about
secrets she is her definition of
cheating is different than mine hers is
about sexual encounters here's where
that that here's why i want to stay away
from that it doesn't matter i don't want
you to get into a semantics conversation
with your husband about is this cheating
or is it not cheating am i cool or not
cool
that's not that's not the issue here the
issue is your boundaries
well see i don't think it's about boobs
no no it's not it's about i want this
and he's saying
no i don't i don't think i care i really
don't like because like i said i like to
have dirty naughty fun like you do care
sarah you care well i think i care
because it's like you pretend to like be
somebody who doesn't like that and like
if you like that then just be honest
with me and be like yeah we're going to
a strip club it's going to be a good
time but you know i'm coming home you
know what i'm does that make sense yes
your husband's not telling you the truth
that's what it feels like it's like just
it's not what it feels like that's what
it is
so why does he do that
because you're not being honest with
yourself
you're not super cool with this
you don't think so no
but i want to be
great you know what i want 20 million
dollars i want it so bad
you're on the right track man you look
sold out
yeah dude
yeah it sold a bunch so i'm i think i'm
approximately
19 million 980 000 away from my goal
so here's the deal like
you you just
what do i do with this man
you have to own the fact that you feel
devalued
so then if i give him a rule do i tell
him not to go because that feels yucky
what feels more yucky
your husband lying to you or your
husband
saying i don't really care how you feel
these are my bros dude
i i think he would
like listen to me if i told him that but
like i don't
so why why are you so afraid to tell
them what you think what you what you
find value in
why because i just like i don't know i
just like have this image of myself and
i want
to not be
i don't want to not care you know what i
mean like i want you to
it's okay trying to force yourself to
not okay here's a sideways example and
if this example goes off the rails
because it just came to me then they're
gonna edit it out and this will never
exist okay
um in when i was the dean of students at
a law school one of the things we would
do is i gave everybody a question here i
think goes out to southern illinois is a
questionnaire just on behavior practices
how much sex are you having how much do
you drink how much weed do you smoke
when's the last time you did cocaine
right questions like that
and
the purpose of this
was just social norming
just so you could find out really about
your classmates and then what i would do
is i'd get up and read the data and
here's what was wild they would ask
people the their questions about
themselves and then they would ask the
questions about what they thought their
classmates were doing
and there was always a significant gap
between how much
people actually drank
how drunk they were all the time
and how much people thought they were
drinking
because people thought they were people
were drunk 95 of the time and they were
really drinking 60 of the time
and one of the most damning statistics
ever and i'd get up and i'd read it to
the class because i was like hey here's
what you all think but here's what truth
is if you don't want to drink and you
think well 90 of the people are then
you're gonna find yourself in a
situation that you don't like you're
going to compromise your own values
because you want to belong and the
desire to belong is so strong so strong
the one that used to break my heart
was the number of and this was
particularly among the female cohort of
students
the number of people who had to consume
two to three alcoholic drinks
to feel sexy to engage in sexual
behavior
and every year i got up in front of the
class
the whole
crew and said
if you have to consume substances
to tampen down your own value system
don't
it's there for a reason
and you have a set of values
that mean something to you one of them
is honesty one of them is fidelity one
of them is you want to be the only
person
being all up on your husband
one of them is do you value me more than
your stupid college friends
right you've got these values wow and
you're doing
everything you can to squash them in the
name of cool chick
yeah
and hear me say your
values matter
so what do i tell him
what do i do
what you feel
and what you know to be true
this isn't an argument about cheating if
if it's cheating for you then that's the
words you use and i'll honor that i
think it is it's just like it's it's
deceptive it's lying and it's i don't
feel comfortable with this
period
and here's my here's my promise to you
this isn't the only thing
right
sucks for you i've been doing this a
long time
there's a bunch of stuff in your home
that you're not super down with
that you do everything you can whether
it's to smoke a little to drink a little
bit more to wear something a little
whatever it is
your your find ways to squash how you
really feel about a thing
to try to
live up to some fantasy some myth
mythical character you've created that
you think your husband wants
it's not even that i think he wants that
i don't know
it's just like me i guess
yeah
so here's how i've always been
everywhere i'm always the life of the
party like i'm always the loudest i'm
always like you know the whatever like i
always want to have sex with time you
know that's me that's like my yeah damn
well there's different between one have
sex all the time and being the life of
the party
one of those is
awesome one of those is exhausting
fair
which one's weird
i mean wanting to have sex all the time
with your husband it's pretty awesome
um yeah wanting to always
it's a defense mechanism
being the life of the party it's a way
that you can wave your wand over here
and go everybody look over here
so that you don't really see what's
going on
and i'm talking as a former life of the
party
now i'm a total drag on the party you
know why because i don't care
damn how do you get there
that was a lot of therapy for that it's
a lot
yeah there's a lot of therapy yeah
honestly here's where it is it started
with me looking in the mirror and being
honest about what i felt about stuff i
had to start telling the truth to myself
and i had to start telling the truth to
my wife and i started telling the truth
to my close friends
and what do i do
here here's here's the honest-to-god
truth
um i want to be very careful how i say
this
um
i don't want to bring people into this
unnecessarily
i've been in a lot of weddings in my
life and i've skipped a number of
bachelor parties
and those people are still the closest
friends i have on the planet
and i'll still trust them with my kids
if i'm in the hospital
i would trust them with my wife
if i got deployed overseas
i love them and i trust them
and also i didn't participate in their
bachelor party
right and it's not a matter of judgment
it's a matter of me
i chose not to
right and so it's not an either or
i also go to bed at midnight when i'm
everyone's hanging out
i'm
lame my company's we're going to do an
event in vegas and i'm like dude how can
i get out of this i can go to bed at 11
not get out of the event but
like when the event's over at 10 i bet i
can be in bed by 10 45 i'm just not cool
i'm just not and my friends that are
really my friends they still love me
anyway and they make fun of me and they
would but it doesn't compromise my
marriage and it doesn't compromise my
personal values
and it doesn't make me not love them any
less and it doesn't make them love me
any less right
so you've cur you've painted yourself
into a corner where if i do this then
he's gonna you don't know that
the only way forward is you'd be gonna
start telling the truth with yourself
and start telling the truth with your
values with him
and that's hard because my guess is you
have not done that a long time and that
doesn't compromise you
being a fun rambunctious sexy wife it
doesn't compromise that at all in fact
it provides infinitely more freedom
there
because right now you're trying to be
reckless and fun
and you're shackled to a story
you're gonna have reckless and fun
adventures in your bedroom
go completely unshackled
these things this my knowledge is really
getting ugly here it's getting pretty
pretty sideways pretty fast that's not
what i meant you know what i meant sarah
but listen
the fewer the fewer values you have to
tamp down the more energy you have to
expend
have excitement enjoy it fun
i hate that you're in this situation
but how do you have the conversation you
sit down and have the conversation say
this is how i feel
and you're worth that you're worth your
values we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too i love living in a
new home but i gotta be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in the mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back
why not let's take one more let's just
take one more let's go to
charlottesville and talk to james what's
up brother james
dr john it's great to talk to you thank
you
that's awesome what's up dude
so i'm gonna try to get through this i'm
in quite a uh a predicament right um
my wife unfortunately was uh diagnosed
with stage four cancer oh
what kind
yeah
colon cancer oh
gosh
yes and it is absolutely on the rise so
for those who are listening out there
please please please get checked yeah
now my wife when i tell you she was the
absolute epitome of health yeah she was
a long-distance runner
she was wanting marathon half marathon
races
and just out of the balloon she gets hit
with stage four colon cancer
what's that what's the timeline
uh
well they said
possibly two years
that they don't know right now it it
depends uh we still have a couple scans
we need to get through to give us a
little bit more of
of the direction but currently she's on
chemo
and we're also trying some um some
natural supplements
did she have surgery
she did she had surgery um
and it worked for a little while we
thought
but unfortunately it came back i'm so
sorry man
thank you sir that's a that's a
that is a
car wreck punch in the gut man
it is it is and uh you know we've got
great support
um i've got we've got two young boys who
are who are tenants well um but my
question for you today is i i work for
honestly it's a fantastic company they
treat me very very well
the benefits are fantastic
and my pay is really good
the only problem is dr john i'm just not
into my work anymore okay
and i don't know if it's because
of my wife and the situation she's going
through but i i kind of felt like this a
little bit before she was even diagnosed
that this just is not me and i'm at a
point now where i literally could just
walk out but i can't yeah now i had the
opportunity to get back into the family
business
but that would require require us to up
and move from where we currently are to
a different state
[Music]
now i wanted to get your opinion i
wanted to get your expertise um i i just
don't know what to do
and i'm lost i am yeah and i'll admit it
well i'm you're just you're a brave
loving husband man
your ability to say that stuff out loud
is hard and
um
you can hear my voice i mean it's yeah
thank you for being brave so
um i'm not gonna use names again i don't
have permission to tell the story um so
i'm gonna be rather vague but
one of my best friends on all of the
planet
um
was married
um to an
extraordinary
person
um
who
got brain internal brain cancer and
passed away
um
hung in there a lot longer than
everybody thought and then it went
pretty quick
and i remember
calling because i was thinking about a
wild career shift i was gonna either go
to law school or i was gonna go get a
phd in psychology and i was gonna do
something totally radically different
with my life
and this person
did one of those
jobs
and so i called and said hey i'm
thinking about this and this and then
what about this what about this
and here was his answer to me
john none of that matters
and that was the first time my stomach
dropped
and
he was right
so here's why i tell you that
does job satisfaction matter yes you
your body is circling the wagons right
now and you're not your food's gonna
taste different you're gonna lose joy in
almost every facet of your life
yes so that's completely and totally
normal
and there will be seasons when you will
be super husband because that's what you
are and you will turn all the lights on
you'll make sure there's flashlights
everywhere and everybody's smiling and
you'll whiten your teeth
and then you'll have moments when you
are dragged into the abyss
right
fair absolutely okay
so my advice and wisdom would be what my
counselor told me
after a loss in my family
you cannot make a major life decision
for a year
just sit
and
everything is crushing you right now and
the temptation is to start looking
around and finding things to throw rocks
at
because you're going to be raged out
because your wife is beautiful and
healthy and did everything right and
this isn't part of that script
and then you're going to go through how
devastatingly
easy stage one colon cancer is to deal
with
and how
tragically un difficult stage four is to
deal with
you what i mean absolutely if they
haven't already the idiots who love you
in your life and i say that with a smile
on my face will be telling you well you
should have got checked wow why didn't
you and you're like thinking i know
and yet here we are right and so yeah
you're going to get all the well-meaning
advice and all this
my recommendation to you man is to
hunker down with your wife you've got a
great company who's taking care of you
financially it's going to help you with
these insane medical bills
and what it's going to give you is a
foundation to walk through the next two
years
so i've been focusing a lot on the the
future too do i just need to focus on
day by day
no and no that's the problem but that
hurts me though a lot more when i focus
in the future because i focus on
oh my gosh am i going to have to bury
her because honestly neither one of us
want to be buried in this area yeah we
want to be buried but i don't quite know
where that is yet either yeah so no it's
not this area here's the thing
um
you'll get the single worst slash
greatest gift
the worst gift is that you're gonna have
to potentially
bury your spouse
yeah and you're going to have a what
a it's a spiritual like you'll get to
sit and look her in the eye and say
let's walk through this together
absolutely and nobody wants that gift
that's a gift i'm happy to hand back i
don't want to open that i don't want to
unwrap it whatever
and you get to say
with your feet propped up on your front
porch after the sun's gone down because
i know you can't look at each other and
have this conversation and still speak
so where do you want to be buried
yeah
it's going to feel surreal
right right
and so there's a healthy mix of future
planning you have to be
live in reality
and you want to soak up every last
second
yes
and so yes getting done before one or
two or three men in your life that you
trust
to rally the troops and say here's what
we're looking at the next 18 to 24
months
i'm gonna need help with x i'm gonna
need help with why and you know what
else you're gonna give them a great gift
because they're sitting there with their
thumbs in the air going uh okay what do
we do what do we do
i need you to help find a place because
we've chosen
nashville tennessee we've chosen houston
texans we've chosen wherever that's
where we want to buy our plots here's
some money that's your job
and i need some help we're here with the
will i need some help here with right so
you're gonna get some guys that i'm
gonna call you at 2am sometimes crying
out of the shower and i need you just to
answer the phone
have that conversation with them okay
absolutely and
i mean i i'm like um
yeah
man
i'm heartbroken man
yeah
it's tough
tell me about it real quick
funny beautiful
cranky
type a
all the above
what did she hassle you about most
what does she hassle me about the most
yeah what's she just passing about
whoo
um
that's a good one i mean she can hassle
me about a lot
what's the big one i for some reason i
hang up my shirts and i put all my
clothes in the hamper but
i stack my pants up i don't know why
ah the dishes i mean i sometimes i just
leave the dishes there come on jay i'm
just kidding
what's the hardest you ever seen her
laugh
um oh gosh when we get
her brother will send us pictures of uh
of the dog or send his picture just fun
pictures and yeah
i mean she'll get a good belly laughs
you know i like to be a comedian too so
i'll uh
i'll make her laugh a little bit she
laughs at your jokes my wife doesn't
laugh at my jokes at all
okay hey here here's um you'll have
little ones
we do okay how old
10 and 12. oh jeez
how much do they know
uh they know that the cancer came back
and they're obviously devastated
they don't know what the extent is and
we just we
don't want to have that conversation
with them yet okay
i think it's wise to get some data
and some very a very clear path before
you sit down with them
um
here's what would be a great great great
gift
this is a legacy gift okay
okay um i want you and your wife to get
a journal i want you to begin writing
each other notes
on the daily if you can
okay but how much you love her
what today was like
um
what you miss what's funny what's this i
thought about the future today and i'm
scared
um
i thought about
you know the last few days and i got
nervous or whatever and i'm wondering if
i'm in all those things i want you to
write that stuff down
because your 10 and 12 year old are
going to be 26 and 24 someday
yes and they're going to sit down with
you over chips and queso and margarita
and they're going to say tell me about
mom
right
and you're going to be able to say i'll
tell how about she tell you
right
james we love you
i said i wasn't going to do this that
doesn't matter what you say man yeah it
doesn't matter what you say
you're losing the love of your life and
your best friend on planet earth
[Music]
yeah it's tough what you say doesn't
matter right it's just gonna come
so hear me say this you're surrounded by
people who love you
absolutely i appreciate it dr john
i'll walk alongside you through this
whole thing you holler anytime i can be
of help or support you let me know okay
definitely thank you sir god bless you
guys i appreciate it we tell your wife
we love her too
will do thank you sir okay all right
blessings to you man take care thank you
sir bye-bye
[Music]
we'll be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back as we wrap up
today's show
just kept thinking about this song
it's
it's one of the greatest songs ever
written by the one and only james taylor
it's called fire and rain it goes like
this
just yesterday morning they let me know
you were gone suzanne the plans they
made put an end to you and i walked out
this morning and i wrote down this song
and i just can't remember who to send it
to
i've seen fire and i've seen rain and
i've seen sunny days that i thought
would never end and i've seen lonely
times when i could not find a friend but
i always thought
i'd see you again
i thought i'd see you one more time
there's just a few things coming my way
this time around i thought i'd see you
[Music]
take it easy we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode one of the
main issues that's happening right now
is related to money but he has and even
through therapy and all that has never
backed down from the position that he
does not answer to me
financially if you have
whittled away a decision in your
marriage and it is final call there's
something else going on money is a
symptom here why do you want to quit
yelling well i was raised in a really
wonderful home but both of my parents
would resort to
to yelling let me reframe something
okay you were raised in an abusive
household
[Music]